[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
foreign
[Music]
the world is kind of like uh blade
runner right you know how blade runner
is los angeles
future dystopia yes mato is like
shanghai 1920's future dystopia
so that's that's the city of nato and
that's so and you'll you'll see a lot of
the aesthetics
based off of that
let's get right into it
i'm just gonna honor through this and
just just tell you what for the sake of
demo
so basically you start out as a
private investigator and it's like all
noir
games or
content right where your your
protagonist is
i know right let's go
i'm already excited i like shady
individuals being for me
it's safe to go okay
very very outstanding individuals
unfortunately we can't hear the audio so
the same production company that did the
persona 5 voice-over game yeah the
voiceovers are the same ones that are
doing you can't you can't just glide
past that
so when you hear it you'll
you know you'll know you'll know oh they
put a box away
oh they're taking him somewhere so again
this is this is just a demo it's alpha
it it was uh this build is from like
early june
right now it's september so
we we've gone like years ahead where
we're in beta right now it'll be out in
2023
so again you see like we have the new
moore thing going with the femme fatale
love it he's the boss he's the boss all
right love the environment back up very
very good
and so yes there's a lot of intrigue a
lot of mystery
now during the youtube literally on that
question are there are there dialogue
choices in the game or no that's not the
style of gaming dialogue choices yeah
you'll see it uh right here right now
let's go oh wow i absolutely love the
art style
do this check out and there's modulation
there's your choices right
i guess this is a simple demo so
nothing big you know and this is the
type of humor that you'll see so you can
ask what's playing and she's
what's playing these days is like all
right there's a sign right
all right
well in the game you get three you get
as many shots yeah especially in the
demo right so
right here
we're gonna go show this we're not gonna
be hard on this we're gonna go soft okay
okay all right so
oh wow
yeah yeah okay
yeah we hit that soft spot yeah so now
now she knows
right
and this basically starts you off to
to the whole entry right
so she gives you information
and right here
this looks absolutely gorgeous
it is
it feels like a really lived-in
breathing world there's one of those
individuals yeah
and i'm going to say i got to ask up
there if i asked what time engine lies
what is
using uh unity nice
outside man yeah so you see how it's
like very
i
so this is your fast fashion system so
okay we're going here we've got the
little underground
so here's the first cut scene so
the story is right private investigator
there's like these riffs that open up
all over the city and he's trying to
figure out what's going on
and it's like the rabbit hole
as far as development how long have
better lavaliers been in
development that
i want to say it's a hard question not
because of
like the length but also because uh
so
so you see here
wow
so this is kind of like another realm
okay
okay
this this is the this is one of the
combat mechanics right uh right now we
have a single character but eventually
we'll have more characters like at the
same time you know
yeah so at this point we're touching
jrpg's sensibilities
and you'll have different weapons
different skills level
up whole thing this one just takes you
you know just
builds you up and
in a way you're early in the game yeah
you're familiar with looking around so
grab right here and go they have kind of
like
relationship
now
in this game essentially dough is is
this ti that works in the real world
and you have
um gram
fighting
so you see here
it gets more powerful
eventually they'll have their own unique
powerful move you know
typical traditional turn base their turn
your turn yeah now as far as the support
action i've seen that here what was that
about so when you get other characters
you can feel the you know it's a party
heel or or like an individual deal or
costume
that have those abilities
so yeah and this is this is a really
simple uh
maze right uh
the the higher your level goes
the the more complicated it gets and you
have like locks
that you have to
do certain things before you can open
the log yeah
all the traditional chairs
sometimes i do walk a couple of
different but then the automatic battle
you have is it that from the
randomizations therefore or is it you
get to set points and they are valid
i know right now
for now
uh they're scrapped
right that makes it feel rough uh but i
don't know if it's gonna be really
rapidly i don't know it's not fair
though
now we have
which gives him more power in his room
and you know
joe has a gun and he's not
yeah he's not doing it
yeah there are somewhere where they're
ultimately still
looking at it's like like
wow you know it's it's like final
fantasy in the bay where where you get
to see like
do you have ultimate
[Music]
you know we're exploring other media um
like you know
and all that
you know
a lot of text in the game
for the sake of convention i have to ask
[Music]
um
[Music]
other locations
you gotta open them up
yes
like that it's really cool moving npcs
in the world
just to give that simulation of a living
breathing kind of a city yeah and that's
really cool
so this is the other uh gameplay that i
want to show you this is the card
card
this is
right he's the one that helped
now again this is simplistic
we're working to make it more strategic
where you get cars and you can create
your own decks
and you know find different ways to
track
his
psyche right so this is his threshold
right right
action points
and
[Music]
so the blue cards affect you and gives
you
uh certain
uh effects
and the red ones you can either attack
these guys
right
or
gosh
now the thing about this also is that
if you keep a card if you like it or not
these enemies actually will
attack you so
sometimes you want to attack these guys
and sometimes you know you just want to
go in for the kills
the premise of this game
on top of that we've also got cnn
stopping by we're gonna let these folks
play the
game right now
so this is dustin neon let me show this
one out throughout the day
uh richard this is a car feature sci-fi
roadway twin-stick shoes
you need to be persuasive
yes
yes
you know it's like being a wife
is
what are we looking
at uh
[Music]
um
to say how many right characters you can
have in your party you know i mean
uh things like that so we're we're
trying to make it balanced and
you know we also hired a native english
writer to help
very impressive
[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast